did you know that two out of every three
guys are going to experience some form
of male pattern ball just by the time
they're 35 I certainly knew if Amir was
more like 25 look I wish keeps have been
around when I was younger because
advancements decides meant that there
are now treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss and help you keep
the hair you have unlike me look it's
too late for me my hair is not coming
back but you don't have to be like me
you could stop your hair loss early
thanks to keeps they offer generic
versions of the only two approved drugs
for treating hair loss by the FDA so you
might have tried them before but never
at a price this low that's right if you
were thinking this is a medicine it's
gonna be expensive you couldn't be more
wrong keep starting to just 10 a month
how does it work well for one thing no
need to go to the doctor's office just
scheduled a quick online consult a
little bit later a discrete package will
arrive at your door and you can use it
in the privacy of your own Heim so look
if you're noticing you're losing your
hair that's not a problem that's going
to fix itself I promise you that do
something about it for a limited time go
to keeps.com
biographics or click the link in the
description below to receive 50 off your
first order and now today's video
Soldier Hunter Trapper Scout Pony
Express Rider Buffalo Bill wore many
hats during the old frontier days but
unlike many of his compatriots he didn't
simply fade away once the old west
turned into a relic of the bygone era if
anything he became even more famous
because that was when Buffalo Bill found
his true calling that of a showman he
decided that the wild west didn't have
to be just another chapter in the
history books it could be a spectacle
capable of enthralling an audience
looking for adventure and excitement and
he was right Buffalo Bill took the
violence the Thrills and the danger of
the old west and distilled them into a
show that toured for decades around
America and Europe people everywhere
flocked in droves to catch a glimpse of
the genuine Wild West experience that
they had read about in so many
newspapers and magazines and dime novels
thus helping Salute by Buffalo Bill's
reputation as the greatest showman to
ever strap on a pair of cowboy boots
William Frederick Cody was born on
February the 26 1846 on a farm outside
Leclair Scott County Iowa his father
Isaac Cody was a Canadian immigrant who
originally relocated to Cincinnati Ohio
where he met a married Bill's mother a
teacher named Marianne Lee [ __ ] before
they both packed up and moved to Iowa
even though the Family Farm proved to be
prosperous the Cody's never stayed in
the same place for long it seems that
Buffalo Bill inherited his wonderlust
and thirst for adventure from his father
who got caught up in the California Gold
Rush and tried to stake his own claim in
1850. the new business venture went
belly up pretty quickly for reasons Bill
never found out but Isaac Cody didn't
want to return to farm life therefore in
1854 the family sold most of what they
had loaded everything else onto wagons
and set out for the rugged and four
lawnlands of Kansas which had just been
incorporated as a territory of the
United States at first young Bill Cody
was thrilled with the move as it was
filled with new experiences his father
took him along on business trips to
conduct trade his family spent time with
Uncle Elijah who ran a general store in
Western Brazil story just across the
Kansas line Bill met real frontiersmen
hunters and Trappist who lived off the
fat of the land he even saw his first
military fort at Leavenworth where a
cavalrymen conducted drills using Sabers
flashing in the sunlight and the
artillery took the ground under them as
it paraded in front of the austruck
youth then things started to go very
wrong very fast first Bill's older
brother died when he fell off a horse
leaving him as second in command he had
to help out their father with his job as
a Trader and then Isaac Cody himself
became one of the first victims of the
violent turmoil known as Bleeding Kansas
as talks grew of turning Kansas into a
new state the big issue of slavery
became somewhat of a contentious point
and by somewhat we mean that it caused
several fights murders and massacres
during the 1850s until it was turned
into a moot point by the Civil War Isaac
Cody was a free stator or a Free Soil
man as bill called him meaning that he
didn't want slavery to come to Kansas he
was opposed and usually outnumbered by
pro-slavery settlers often referred to
as border raffians because many of them
came from neighboring Missouri which was
all aboard the slavery train one day in
June 1856 Isaac and Bill were returning
from Fort Leavenworth when they were
accosted by a group of men who had spent
most of that day getting drunk and
getting angry over those no good free
Status by that point word had gotten
around town that Isaac Cody was against
slavery so are they way laid him and
demanded that he explained himself this
was all for sure of course Isaac trying
to calm them down and reason with them
only made them more belligerent until
one of the men by the name of Charlie
Dunn snuck up behind him and stabbed him
in the back as Isaac collapsed to the
ground Dunn went in for a second stab to
finish the job at which point
ten-year-old Bill Cody rushed him to
defend his father even though the crowd
seemed okay with Isaac Cody's murder
some of them hadn't crossed far enough
into evil villain territory to be okay
with done killing a young child in front
of them so they stopped him and the
angry mob eventually dispersed Isaac
Cody was taken home and his wife managed
to nurse him to health up to a point he
became weak and a frail man a mere shell
of what he used to be even worse people
still wanted him dead so he couldn't
show his face around town anymore just
being there endangered his entire family
So eventually a few other free soilers
managed to take him safely to Ohio while
the rest of the Cody's lived off the
meager crops that they had and the
animals that bill managed to catch
everyone hoped for a happy ending where
the time away from danger would help
Isaac Cody regain his strength and that
ultimately the family would be reunited
but that's not what happened Isaac Cody
did return home in the spring of 1857
but he was deathly ill never truly
recovering from the Stab Wound he died a
few days later leaving 11 year old Bill
Cody as the new man of the family
[Music]
although he was still just a kid bill
was determined to become a breadwinner
for his mother and sisters his first job
was with the Russell majors and Wardle
Transportation Company his role was to
drive caviar which meant that he rode
behind the Wagon Train herding cattle
that were transported alongside Freight
or passengers bill made 40 a month which
was enough to support his family but he
soon learned of the dangers that came
with the job one night while on the road
to Fort Kearney the wagon trains were
attacked by the soup amid the chaos and
the Bloodshed Bill saw the shadowy
profile of a Sioux Warrior who had his
gun pointed somewhere below him without
any time to think Bill grabbed the
Mississippi egg rifle slone across his
shoulder aimed to pull the trigger
causing the dark figure to fall to the
ground following the attack word of
Bill's deed spread around and even made
the local newspaper where Bill Cody was
proclaimed the youngest Indian Slayer of
the Plains now you might think this
little episode would prompt him to find
another job but he did just the opposite
Bill Cody realized that a life of
adventure out on the planes was the only
life for him thanks to his Newfound
reputation Bill didn't have trouble
finding spots on new wagon trains so he
did that for a few years until the Pony
Express came along in 1860 the same
company that gave Bill Cody his first
job had an idea for a new operation a
mail service that ran across the
heartlands of America from the Midwest
all the way to California who would
employ Brave experienced Riders who
could cover up to 100 miles before
passing the parcel to a new Fresh Rider
waiting for them at station set up along
the Route truth be told this relay
system was not some new innovation
Genghis Khan did a similar thing and
even a way before him the first Persian
Empire used it to great success around
500 BC and the reason why this reload
system was used so often was simply
because it worked the Pony Express
became the fastest way to deliver
messages from one coast of America to
the other it was hard and dangerous work
since Riders often had to Traverse lands
filled with perils hence the infamous
Pony Express ad which read wanted young
skinny worry fellas not over 18. must be
expert Riders willing to risk death
daily orphans preferred wages 25 per
week alas it seemed that the ominous
advertisement wasn't real having been
made up by a journalist in the early
20th century also if dubious veracity
was Bill Cody's role with this mail
service it has long become an intrinsic
part of his Legend Buffalo Bill joined
the Pony Express when he was a teenager
and became its most famous Rider he
certainly claimed it often enough and
other people vouched for him but his
name cannot be found in the official
records so this might simply be an
oversight from a time when record
keeping wasn't exactly but Paramount
concern or it could have been some [ __ ]
and Bull story Bill served as eager
public to add to his exploits it's
unlikely to be the only one even if Bill
Cody did work for the Pony Express he
didn't do it for very long nobody did in
fact because the Pony Express has been
romanticized and transformed into an
integral part of wild west law and
people tend to forget that the business
was a dismal failure that only lasted
for a year and a half before going
bankrupt that's because it appeared
shortly before another means of
communication one that was truly an
innovation a telegraph as soon as the
first transcontinental line was
established in October 1861 the Pony
Express became redundant and was forced
to close its doors
as was the case with most Americans Bill
Cody's life changed in 1861 with the
outbreak of the Civil War his family had
strong union sympathies and Bill wanted
to join the fight but his mother made
him promise not to do it because she
couldn't bear losing him too Bill
promised but clearly had his fingers
crossed behind his back because that
same year he joined the red-legged
scouts a local company commanded by
Captain Bill tough although the
red-legged scouts often worked alongside
the regular army they were civilians
whose stated goal was to protect Kansas
from incoming Raiders and Guerrilla
soldiers so Cody saw this more as
protecting his home rather than taking
part in the war clearly Cody thought
this was an acceptable loophole but he
stopped pretending altogether in 1863
once his mother passed away and he
joined the seventh Kansas Cavalry as a
guide and Scout his sisters were married
by that point so he didn't have to worry
about providing for anyone else anymore
when the Civil War was over Bill thought
that it was time to start his own family
so in 1866 he married a woman named
Louisa federici and the two went on to
have four children together in 1867 Cody
had a short stint working for the Kansas
Pacific Railway hunting Buffalo to help
feed the workers building the railroad
it was a brief but important part of his
life because this job gave Cody a new
moniker which immortalized him in the
pantheon of wild west Legends thanks to
his hunting prowess Bill Cody became
known as Buffalo Bill and the label was
well deserved if the stories or anything
to go by allegedly Bill killed over 4
000 Buffalo during an eight-month period
And even had his own special rifle for
it a Springfield 50 caliber trapdoor
needle gun which he named Lucretia
Borgia after an Infamous 15th century
Italian Femme Fatale the buffalo
population got a reprieve in 1868 when
Cody returned the Army the Civil War may
have ended but the American government's
conflicts with various Native American
tribes were ongoing so there was still a
great need for a man of Bill's talents
he was even promoted to chief of Scouts
that same year and in 1872 he received a
Congressional Medal of Honor for Valor
in action somewhat controversial the
government later revoked the honor in
1917 after they created a new hierarchy
for military medals and deemed that some
recipients such as Buffalo Bill no
longer fit the criteria their decision
was ultimately reversed in 1989 and
Bill's medal was reinstated following a
long campaign by its descendants 1872
was a landmark year for Buffalo Bill
first came the Medal of Honor then came
the visit of the grand eucalyxi
alexandrovich of Russia son of Emperor
Alexander II he was a Goodwill
Ambassador or a publicity tour of the
United States and word came down from
President Ulysses S Grant himself to
make the young Duke feel at home it was
Alexi's 22nd birthday and to celebrate
it he wanted to take part in a buffalo
hunt it was the Duke his Entourage a few
American generals and none other than
Buffalo Bill acting as their guide on
the trip allegedly Bill even loaned
Alexia's trusty hunting rifle Lucretia
to bag his first Buffalo it was a
successful hunt all around and the
Grateful Duke lavished everyone with
expensive champagne and luxurious
presents to celebrate the event more
than that the Royal buffalo hunt as it
was known was the Talk of the Town and
front page news on every newspaper in
the country this gave Buffalo Bill his
first taste of Fame and he liked it that
same year Bill took to the stage for the
first time courtesy of American writer
and promoter Ned bun blind now if you're
not familiar with Ned bunheim that's
because his main job was to make other
people famous and he liked to focus on
Wild West characters which he featured
in dime novels that sold greatly
exaggerated Tales of their Adventures
his biggest success story was Wild Bill
hickert and honestly bunline deserves
almost as much credit for turning Hickok
into a legend of the old west as Bill
himself in 1872 his new pet project was
Buffalo Bill given all the attention he
received following Grand Duke alexey's
hunting trip the two already knew each
other and Bill Cody had a hankering for
the Limelight so it didn't take a lot of
convincing from Buntline to have Buffalo
Bill star in his new stage show titled
the Scouts of the Prairie the show
premiered on December the 16th 1872 at
the Nixon Amphitheater in Chicago
alongside Bill and bartline there act
also included another famed Frontiersman
called Texas Jack amahundro and an
Italian dancer named giuseppina
moralachi reception to the show was
mixed the critics absolutely hated it
but the public loved it the Big Mama's
House of its day if you will every
single newspaper in Chicago panned it
singling out the durable performance of
its 23 year old leading man Bill Cody
who delivered his lines after the manner
of a diffident Schoolboy in his Maiden
effort however the audiences loved the
rough and tough style of Buffalo Bill it
made him feel genuine he was a guy who
actually fought in Wars who actually
killed men who hunted buffalo on the
planes the fact that he was young and
handsome didn't hurt either and just
like that a star was born
[Music]
the following year Bill split from Ned
Buntline took Texas Jack with him and
developed his own act titled Scouts of
the planes he even added while Bill
Hickok to the show one of the few
figures of the old west who were more
famous than him however this was after
hickok's Glory Days his eyesight had
gone bad and he couldn't find a job as a
Lawman anymore so this was more of an
attempt from Gody to help out a friend
however if you've seen our biographics
video on Wild Bill you'll absolutely
already know that Hickok didn't take the
show business as Buffalo billed it he
hated being on stage and he lasted only
for a few months Bill Cody toured with
his troop for the next decade or so he
took one memorable break in 1876
following the Battle of Little Bighorn
AKA Custer's Last Stand General Custer
had been a friend to Cody he was even
there for the Duke's buffalo hunt
Buffalo Bill felt obliged to rejoin the
scouts and help avenge his Fallen
comrade which she did at the Battle of
War Bonnet Creek where the fifth Cavalry
Regiment defeated a group of Shan
according to Legend after gunning down a
famed Warrior named yellow hair bill
helped him and shouted the first scalp
Custer whether or not this gruesome
display of Vengeance actually happens we
can't say but Bill later Incorporated a
reenactment of it into his show Bill's
feelings towards Native Americans were
complicated he didn't seem to mind
fighting them in battles he certainly
didn't mind exploiting them for his show
but he was also a proponent of their
civil liberties and defended them in
public at a time when doing that could
have been career suicide he stated for
centuries they've been hounded from the
Atlantic to the Pacific and back again
they had their wives a little ones to
protect and they were fighting for their
existence every Indian outbreak that
I've ever known has resulted from broken
promises and broken treaties by the
government and if you think that
position is a bit incongruous you should
know that bill was also in favor of
Buffalo conservation even though he
killed them by the thousands in 1883
Cody took his act to new heights when he
founded Buffalo Bills Wild West a
large-scale spectacle that was much more
comparable to a circus than a stage show
it toured around the country and
featured parades races shootouts roping
and riding Marksmanship contests and
reenactments of famous battles already
famous figures of the West such as
Sitting Bull and Calamity Jane appeared
as storytellers while other performers
such as Annie Oakley found Fame by
starring in this show just after a few
years the show became so popular that
Buffalo Bill took it to Europe he
performed at Queen Victoria's Jubilee
during the 1887 World's Fair his
six-month stint in London garnered over
2 million total visitors improved so
popular that Cody was invited to Stage
the show in other countries in front of
European royalty and even Pope Leo the
13th it's not an exaggeration to say
that at the turn of the century Buffalo
Bill was one of the most famous
Americans in the world if not the most
famous Bill Cody may have been a great
showman but that didn't make him a great
businessman for most of the wild west
shows run the administrative side of
things was handled by Bill's manager
Nate Salisbury when they died in 1902
his role was taken up by circus promoter
James Bailey of Barnum and Bailey Fame
but he also died a few years later in
1906 and he left the company in Dar
Financial Straits Buffalo Bill had no
choice but to sell part of the business
to a competitor named Major Gordon Lilly
who went by porny Bill They promoted
their new show as the two bills but Cody
still had to borrow heavily to keep it
going he wasn't helped by the fact that
people were starting to get a little
bored with the whole Wild West stage
show movies were the hit new thing that
everyone clamored for on top of this
Buffalo Bill's Public Image was damaged
by his unsuccessful attempt to divorce
his wife she accused him of sleeping
with women from his show while he
accused her of trying to poison him Cody
hoped for a quiet and Speedy divorce but
Louise of fredericki was old school and
thought that her husband and wife were
supposed to stick together to The Bitter
End she fought all of his efforts to end
their marriage and their Court
proceedings made juicy material for the
Scandal columns ultimately she won at
the who became estranged but stayed
married for 51 years some sources claim
they even reconciled in their old age
Buffalo Bill remained a performer until
the day he died although by that point
he needed to be helped onto his horse
before every show he passed away a on
January the 10th 1917 at the age of 70
while visiting his sister in Denver
Colorado unfortunately most of his
fortunate dwindle by this point and his
memorabilia always sold off to pay
creditors even in a period full of
memorable characters like the wild west
Buffalo Bill managed to carve an image
for himself that was not only popular
but also unique and still captivates
audiences to this very day
[Music]